Halle Berry is absolutely Furious that
Drake used her picture of her getting
slimed for uh the cover of his song I
believe it's a single it's not uh for
the album
also side notes
phenomenal rollout to this album
he has held the conversation about the
album coming out for how long one month
at least a month or a month and a half
he's just controlled the conversation
and I'm like
as long as you can milk it
you milk it because you can always drop
the album and then all those people that
were excited aren't gonna go listen
they're gonna listen once the album
drops we know that for a fact so it's
how long can you get people listening or
no talking about it helping you promote
it speaking about to their friends
without you actually dropping a month
and a half is fantastic fantastic and
also having like the IQ or the EQ to
know what the energy is yeah yeah yeah
people talking about it okay let's drop
something oh it's good let's Coast for a
little bit Yeah and then when the album
eventually drops it'll be the right time
yeah but not being so locked into an
exact date the right time does it have
to be the peak of the people talking
about it I don't think it does no I
think they calculate a few things like
who else is dropping that weekend
um the if all the clearances for the
samples
yeah that usually pushes things back a
lot got it yeah because he he said
somewhere he's like I could either stop
doing some shows and finish this album
or we could push the album back and I
don't want to cancel the shows yeah so
who's going to want you to cancel it
exactly yeah
yeah it's just really it this is a
really interesting rollout to control
the conversation for a month and a half
yeah yeah so it's it's hard to hold
energy for a week
he's Drake
[Music]
not really really well done okay but uh
what we're really talking about this is
Halle Berry thing is she really mad she
fake mad should she be mad didn't she
didn't he ask her and she said no no
she's saying he never asked her
permission yeah okay yeah I'm like you
should be mad sorry she should be mad
but does she own the picture that's the
thing I don't even know if it's up to
her to get the permission unless he's
smashed it kind of makes me feel he's
smashed because otherwise why would he
call her does he have your number are
you guys talking is there a personal
connection he's Drake you can get in
contact with anyone if he needs to oh
I'm saying I don't think Hallie's at the
level talk to her like that
but that's more like
but yeah we gotta talk about that
Mexican aliens but but yeah so what's
the thing do you I mean this is just
great for him more controversy more
people talking about it more things of
course he's not gonna call for all the
dogs he's being a dog there you go yeah
also her criticism was not that bad it
was like man for someone I respect I
wish you asked yeah that's a very like
but also if she says anything it's news
TMZ's picking it up it's more marketing
it's almost like Hallie he can't ask
he can't ask because by not asking
you'll talk about it and then create
news if he puts it out and you yeah he
asked me he was so sweet and polite and
kind and he offered me royalties and it
was just he's just the best person no no
new story at all yeah I think didn't
Kanye kind of do that with the uh oh
famous the music video with it had all
the people and everyone in the builders
in it yeah and like it just if you're in
the video it's like what's your comment
what do you have to say about you being
in this very famous video everyone
commented either they comment or they
don't comment and then what does it not
comment mean what's going on it's just
like create you're just pulling people
into your orbit and Drake did this with
the 21 album roll out when he did the
fake vote cover and then Vogue was
really upset about that and then they
sued him and so that was a whole big
story yeah around the album so that's
fantastic it's just big enough now that
pulling people into his orbit is a lot
easier yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah
something to think about man the rollout
it's really impressive that's amazing
yes it's really really impressive and I
wonder if other artists try to create
something similar also it helps that
he's already touring this is another
thing that I thought was interesting I
figured you dropped the album a few
months before you go tour and then you
tour that album plus your old stuff but
he starts the tour and teases the album
during the tour now you're teasing the
album during Peak conversation about you
already because you're touring
so you're not even worried about touring
this album just yet and I wonder if
that's because
you'll never tour an album again
when people go see a drake show they
need to see this they need to see all
the things yeah you ain't gonna just
tour your little album you're gonna play
the hits yeah so if he's going maybe
he's going well if I got to play the
hits no matter what it don't matter when
I drop and if there's bangers on this
one they want to see it on the next tour
and if there ain't people are less
inclined to buy tickets for the tour
because they're like oh I didn't like
this album is he touring this album I
didn't even know musicians just toured
albums like that I thought they were
always playing hits because there's so
much replay value for fans what they
usually would do back in the day would
do is tour the majority of the new album
plus a couple bangers but it would be
the okay
yeah now I think it's flopped is it like
flip-flops so it's like now it's
majority of that catalog a couple from
the new Jordan and but I think it's
after Drake or everyone everyone pretty
much like for like for example Beyonce
is doing the old uh songs that are the
Super Smash Hits but she is doing the
majority of this new album and that was
Taylor from brilliant idiots she was
bothered by that she's like I kind of
wanted more of the hits yeah I didn't
want all this out because you might not
fall in love with this album just yet
yeah it takes time to fall in love with
an album A lot of times and it might
just not be your best album yeah so what
protects the tour is knowing that
they're gonna go see the whole show it's
just a drake show you're coming to see
Drake and forever it will be Drake and I
think it would be a mistake if you drop
an album while on tour because the the
tour set track everything is like
planned out and to change something this
late in the game what happens if one saw
super slaps oh wow so what you're saying
which I think is is genius what you're
saying is is that he was never we're
gonna put the album out in the first
place that's correct 100 I think so oh
and that makes perfect sense of course
why would you put the album out if it
succeeds it throws off your track list
if it fails now people are talking about
the album that isn't that good and I
could tarnish the excitement of the tour
use the excitement of the tour
to build the hype for the album that you
dropped the second after the tour is
done yeah I think the album drops during
the tour no I do I think that he kind of
confirm that it can't yeah he said he'll
have to miss some dates or finish the
tour and then the other so he basically
just told you that was not good now
here's the question does he because I
think right now he's only toward America
and North America
I believe so yeah I don't think he did
International
so he's gonna do that yeah it's true
might not
they might not not everybody tours
internationally every single
um oh yeah it seems crazy to pass up
that money yeah it just feels like he is
there's just so much money to be back
from it I mean
or he could remix it a little bit once
the new album drops or then now add some
of the new songs just to give it you
know and then now he almost created a
reason for people to go see him
internationally yeah like American fans
even be like yo I'm flying to blah blah
to go check him because he's gonna he
has you know songs from the new album
and I bet you on the new album he'll
probably have a few uh UK European
African artists so now when he does the
international tour now they're all
popping into those shows and creating
more excitement so that's why you have
this [__] with Central Central seed that
just dropped that's buzzing right now so
when he goes to London and they do that
on the radar [__] that [__] is gonna go
off uh yeah also his dates only go to
October 7th so yeah he'll probably wait
yeah because right now he said that he's
dropping when October 6th
or he might line it up with the OVO [__]
which then that would be like crazy that
makes even more sense yeah like OVO Fest
is in October right so of course you're
gonna drop it around then and then you
do the big Festival in Toronto and then
you play some of it at the festival like
all this makes perfect Robin in
September actually seems so crazy you
have to drop in October OVO that's by
Design that's genius yeah yeah that's
genius yeah now everybody's talking
about it for months before it comes out
by the time it finally comes out you're
so [__] hyped
on this album yeah the one coming up
like burn a boy yeah
[Music]